gamers are you ever tired of Joey and
God not agreeing with your opinions me
too that's why I made miniature Joey and
gone who will never disagree with me wow
isn't that good it's so cute
orange is bad yes and just for fun
there's a little me oh my God take one
guys take away let me see that well
guess what guys you can now have your
very own set of little baby men yeah
look at that and you can have them all
in a little Trash taste plushie bag as
well get in the trash get it get in the
goddamn trash get in there people have
trash tastes belong in here
[Laughter]
so if you want to get your very own
little baby man and trash taste plushie
to go with it make sure to smash that
link in description down below and you
can only get these adorable little baby
men for the next three weeks you'll get
them now on with the video guys let me
let me uh let me sit next to my
girlfriend no get that out of you
and they say we don't have any women on
trash taste what a lie who said a lot
who's this
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste we are the boys and we have
the girls with us as well no the
thoughts we have the thoughts with us
stop calling them that Joey excuse me
have you not seen season two of rent a
girlfriend my favorite anime of all time
we're an embarrassment to like grown man
you know like every other popular
podcast is like Chad's talking about
[ __ ] and then we're just like we're just
like [ __ ] losers we argue about
oranges and then now we have this [ __ ]
what is this [ __ ] I don't even know this
card game is put it away we're not even
sponsored by it all right all right I'll
I'll put it why are you doing free
advertisement yeah I know this is where
someone gave it to us as a free gift
someone someone no it doesn't say ass
they give it to you someone lies
two cards okay someone at a convention
lined up spent all of their time lining
up just so they can give us this gift
and you're throwing it away come on guys
come on yeah oh the corner dude wow that
perfectly landed on the stairs I knew
this was gonna happen that's why I threw
it nice nice anyway how are you guys
doing how are you guys doing it's been a
long week re-acclimated to Japan yet
yeah I have
um not to the weather what do you
re-acclimate define reaction
redefine that word yeah being able to
talk on it I I was I had to react react
yeah
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I think it was leaving Japan that was
much harder because I didn't have a
bidet now I have a bidet so now
everyone's like that's good it feels
like all the chaos in the world is gone
and I've returned finally back to our
first walk yes yeah yeah yeah it's like
the little things that sometimes you
just like you build up a habit and then
you remember that uh you can move
countries and that habit isn't the same
everywhere like for me it's gotten it's
weird now after how much we've
complained about it now coming back to
Japan I'm like oh I have to bring a mask
everywhere again like I've that's that's
something that I've had to reacclimate
to being in Japanese I wish I wish we
didn't have to reacle me to it because
Jesus Christ wearing a mask already
sucks for someone who has facial hair
and now that plus the 97 humidity like
yeah every time I take my mask off my
face is just wet yeah like I have
[ __ ] rabies or something like this
it's like salivating well I think I
don't know who said I might have been
the government I coached making [ __ ] up
you can yeah you could you can you don't
have to wear a mask outside yeah yeah so
it was too damn hot yeah technically
yeah so the Japanese government and
really when was that like back in like
June I think like the start of the rainy
season the Japanese government was like
yeah so this Summer's gonna get pretty
[ __ ] excruciating so uh as long as
you're not in a confined space you can
and we allow the Japanese government
officially allow it we'll allow it for
you to get to take your mask off just so
you guys you know won't have to suffer
yeah and uh Japanese people are like oh
good permission yeah but now they're
just like
but that's because I have facial hair
and it makes it like a moist shower and
I'm like I'm not [ __ ] doing this but
now it's like even though the Japanese
government was like you guys can take
don't worry you guys can take it from us
they're like all right
yeah yeah no one yeah
and everyone has just like if you have
facial hair you just have [ __ ] swamp
chin like the entire time you know and
it was so weird because I remember
flying out of Japan I remember going to
the UK and being like man it feels naked
without my mask on yeah it feels wrong
yeah yeah it did it did it I
after two years of covert it actually
just felt like you had nothing on yeah
because it just felt uncomfortable and
then it took like I'm wearing nothing at
all yes it's like wearing nothing at all
but like after about like I think it was
like two weeks or something I was like
oh this is I can breathe I've forgotten
life I've got this feeling of just being
able to breathe and coming back to Japan
and even now just like finding out that
the government allows people to not wear
masks no one has the balls to not do it
anymore or even like ubereats drivers
wearing like five layers for some reason
they're still wearing a mess while
they're cycling yeah this is like I I
saw a dude giant actually breeds
backpack like like comically large yeah
I don't know what people are ordering
massive amount and then he was wearing
like a full-on like jeans uh a T-shirt
and then a coat over it while delivering
with a mascot I don't and I was like
what the [ __ ] is happening I don't
understand how people survive the winter
here like if you have to [ __ ] double
up in this heat like what do you like
below 10 degrees no no no like how do
you survive the wintertime
yeah yeah I see everyone like I think I
feel really weird because I'm the only
one in my [ __ ] train station wearing
shorts yeah yeah I'm like am I am I am I
the [ __ ] for showing my knees like they
just they just prioritize drip over
everything yeah they're like that but
it's not even dripped because everyone
dresses the same it's that that's how
drip mindset is yeah drip is being the
same as everyone else yeah yeah I'm sure
because like because I don't think they
figured out how to wear shorts because
um because I think like wearing shorts
to them is like anti-trip and you can't
have anti-drip on you need to have like
the base level of drip on I think that
you do not see people wearing shorts
yeah it's so rare and I feel really
weird for being the only one wearing
shorts because I'm just like but because
like I physically can't I I don't know I
mean are they afraid of shin hair or
something like like what like what
is it they don't see your your [ __ ]
ankles yeah right yeah like sorry to
have some [ __ ] you need too much skin
to your skin except for school girls in
the winter where it could be like -20
and they somehow just wear shorts yeah
without any like stockings or leggings
or anything like that exactly yeah I
don't get it there are two types of
people there are two types of drip yeah
it's a drip to wear short things in the
winter it's not how it works you can
never look like amazing unless you're
like a Calvin Klein model wearing shorts
you just look you just look like you're
scuffed I think I think there's no way
of looking good in shorts if you're like
your body is a normal body that's true
that's right you know you know you just
don't you look less attractive than
wearing pants it's just a fact yeah yeah
I I agree like it's it's also that you
can look good in shorts but it's only
one outfit you know and you have to
somehow like stretch this one outfit for
the entire season of Summer I just I
just thought about the guy who did the
the thingy pose then you know how to do
it yeah
he's got the right shirt on you need a
nice like a button down to complement
the shorts but I just don't that's why
I'm always wearing button Downs dude
like look you know I I am I am a man of
drip myself but sometimes you know what
if I have to prioritize between drip and
my balls being as hot as an active
volcano then I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna
prioritize the shorts Comfort because
for me I I try to you know keep aware
about what I wear most of the time so I
look decent but for some reason when I
wear shorts all of that goes out the
window yeah I'm like I don't care how I
look I'm looking for like some nice
breeze where I need [ __ ] breeze on my
legs I don't care how I look I look I
probably look like a [ __ ] clown I
don't know why yeah I'm wearing yeah
Joe's the only one wearing shorts I
don't know how the [ __ ] you guys are
wearing it's not that hot today okay
here's a strat right so when I go
outside I go outside for one second get
inside to go on to get transport to then
come here and they're outside for one
more second then I'm back inside with AC
yeah it's like a yeah it is yeah it's
like a Navy Seals operation if I know
exactly where I'm going I know where all
like I know where the cool spots are I
know what I know I try to minimize the
amount of time in the direct sunlight
and direct heat as much as possible it's
like going from one air conditioned spot
to the other sure but it's like yeah no
but you are right about the whole thing
of like unless you're a [ __ ]
supermodel no one looks good in shorts
because I don't know why for some reason
ugly every time I wear shorts I feel
like a 14 year old child yeah I don't
understand why it is just like you know
even if I might be wearing like a really
nice shirt and it's like you know my
hair is nice today or whatever and I
feel like I'm looking good at the moment
I look anywhere below and I just see my
bad knees I'm just like why do I look
like a child and I that because I love
shorts they're so comfortable they are
I'm like why why are my legs so [ __ ]
ugly you know like why are my bare legs
so ugly why like it is I was like damn
did I have this much hair on my shins
like by default legs are the ugliest
part of the male body unless you do work
out like I should do yeah like they're
just luck like like skeletal or like
chubby it's just like it just looks
weird yeah I don't know because another
thing you have to be aware of is like
the length of your sock as well because
there's nothing that looks more Awkward
than someone wearing really short shorts
and then they just forgot that they had
really long socks on so it just it just
looks unnatural right that's where
that's where the struggle comes in
because I've replaced almost all my
socks with the familymart long socks
so like I either have to like push the
long socks down towards my ankle you
can't do that yeah or I just have to
borrow Aki's like short socks which I'm
currently doing right now yeah and also
the type of shoes they're not too small
no they fit
oh they do look quite girly yeah
I uh I should honestly replace all my
I've got a problem now where I've slowly
replaced socks and boxes over the course
of like two three years so now I've just
got a bunch of mismatching boxes and
socks where like mismatching mismatching
boxes how did you mismatch boxes well if
you're in an ideal world every single
pair of boxes I own would look the same
oh oh I've never got to that I've never
gone that's what I would want what
because because right I hate I don't
know why does it matter what your box is
this is literally [ __ ] American
Psycho [ __ ] you know you're like you
open the drawer all the socks look the
same all the boxes
so right now I'm sure you experienced
this right I have like I want to say
four different types of boxes okay right
so this is just I picked them up or
maybe I bought another pair but it was
different
and like I in my head I have like a soft
ranking of like which ones are the most
comfortable which one I'll go for okay
do you have this where you like you know
which pair of boxes you'd like to wear
the most I there's surely there's gonna
be like
because in my head if they're not
comfortable then I'm just gonna no no no
no I'm not saying okay maybe one of the
pairs are not that comfortable I should
throw them out yeah but the other three
are all comfortable but certain ones are
more more comfortable more luxurious
maybe because they're new ones yeah the
newer ones are more comfortable so so it
comes in terms of the time you've spent
using the Box yeah I have a pair of
boxes that I got from one of our
sponsors ages ago and then by far my
favorite ones yeah and I only have two
of them because we got them for free and
I don't want to buy any more so I'd
rather just replace them so they're
really nice yeah they're really nice and
I'm like ah I like these a lot and these
ones are great and they like when I'm
sweaty if I'm doing sports is something
they're good as well and they wash
really easily and I've watched them like
a billion times and they're great so I
like I want to wear those ones but then
and I'm like man should I just get rid
of all of them but that feels so
wasteful but I want to get them all
uniform and it's even worse with socks
bro my socks game is Wilding yeah I have
like eight different types of [ __ ]
socks and they're all different textures
and thickness and it is a nightmare but
you need that depending on the
environment no I want uniform see that's
why I did the big brain move I replaced
all my socks with family my socks
because now you won't know if they're
mismatched the only other socks that I
want are like let's say I'm going
snowboarding or skiing I have a pair but
they're not in they're not they're like
they're super thick they don't get to
mix yeah daily socks yeah the daily
socks are in their own drawer and
they're it's a it's a [ __ ] mess I've
got like literally eight different
[ __ ] textures going on three of the
textures I'm not a big fan of yeah I
should just Purge it all I should get
rid of them all and just get okay at
what at which point do you look at a
pair of boxes and you go I think it's
time to throw these out because I yeah
because like some people like because
some people will be like oh if there's
like a hole in it or like some people
would be like oh you know the hole's
only small and you know it's not like if
there's a hole in there you better get
[ __ ] rid of it guys
I used to be like the guy where it's
like if the hull is like small enough
where it's you know not gonna get in the
way of being like uncomfortable then
it's like that's maybe got a couple more
months in it so like you know I didn't
want to be wasteful about it but yeah
for a long time I was I got out of the
shower and I was like rummaging through
my my boxes and I picked one up it
looked fine on the front and then I
flipped it around and right on the ask
there was just this giant hole like this
perfectly round hole and I was like damn
that I must have worn this on like Curry
night or something how do you even have
that it was like perfectly where the
[ __ ] would be well this is like a
perfectly round hole like how does that
happen that was a [ __ ] Banger
dab you [ __ ] let it rip man what is
it JoJo Friday
the decibels on that phone it just
ripped right through
where you put your foot in and then
you're like you put your foot in the
sock and as you're about to like get to
the end you're like oh my foot is out of
the socket yeah yeah they're like oh
like my big toe is all the way out yeah
yeah for me my boxes are actually the
biggest indicator of when I should do
laundry right uh because it's not when I
run out what do you mean like oh this
one's got a job okay okay because like
like we said we have a tier list of
boxes the ones that you prefer you're
one a day right huh One A Day right yeah
I do One A Day yeah of course yeah we
all do want to do I'm not an animal I've
met people who do who you know a little
I'd say a little too much yeah like I'm
not discussing I have I have Stan okay I
have standards we have hygiene standards
here but so it goes in order of newest
to oldest right the ones I prefer
wearing so obviously the newest ones are
going to be the most comfortable you can
buy the same pair of boxes every time I
mean see now it's just it's already
Anarchy it's it's not like when you buy
like the Uniqlo or the h m branded boxes
they're all the [ __ ] same you know
they're all the same standards I haven't
gone to like the higher [ __ ] tier s
tier [ __ ] Calvin Klein [ __ ] I don't
like Calvin Klein I literally like just
because they're just super comfortable
and okay you guys don't understand I
have a [ __ ] massive ass and like the
only things that can fit comfortably are
like Calvin Klein I mean I don't know
how yo that dummy thing
it's like the ones in Japan are like
literally the best promotion for Calvin
Klein bro the ones that you don't tell
me you're trying to put on these boxes
stop it from clapping they keep them in
place without without chafing the [ __ ]
out of me because Japanese boxes are
made for like I swear 2D people yeah
yeah and it's like I put these things on
and it's like my balls cannot breathe
immediately
no so like I mean I don't have that
issue I have the issue of I have I have
the issue of it goes for you it goes It
goes in three tiers it goes in high tier
mid-tier low tier High tiers High tears
are the new boxes they're like nice and
crisp and nice and clean they've only
had a few washers it feels good it feels
like it feels like you're it feels like
your balls are like nice you know
they're nice and cup they're like stable
and then you've got like the mid-tier
boxes these are like a few months old
the Fabric's starting to wear a bit and
you're like okay I can get away with
wearing these it's not the it's not the
best box of feel but I can make do yeah
and then when I know I need to do my
washing is when I get to the [ __ ] low
tier boxes the ones I technically should
really think about throwing out you know
like the elasticity is just like kind of
losing its like grip you know it's it's
kind of it's like hanging halfway down
yeah yeah yeah yeah right it's kind of
hanging off and and you're like I should
probably throw these away yeah but if I
did I would get to a point where I would
get to a day where I had no boxes to
wear so that's how when I get to my low
tier boxes that's how that's when I
that's when I know I need to do the
washing wait how many boxes do you own
like roughly like just enough to last
you a week or what by 12 maybe yeah yeah
because I was about to say like I have
enough to last me like at least two
weeks maybe like a week and a half it
depends some I think because we've been
traveling so often now sometimes I just
misplace them I can last about a week
and a half but I get to my low tears
after a week and that's that's that's
how I know that's how I know because I
never because if I didn't have my low
tears I just get to a week and I'm like
[ __ ] I I'm gonna be disgusting why would
you not just replace your low to your
stuff with just some brand new pair of
boxes I know sometimes it's just it's
just routine I I like for me I
subconsciously know I need to do the
washing and it actually gives me a
reason to do the washing because I don't
want to wear my low tier boxes but if I
just add High tier boxes I'd be like
[ __ ] well I just forget to do the
washing because because you know you can
get away with wearing a t-shirt again a
day or two you know you can get away
with wearing trousers you can't get away
wearing the same boxes every day you
know how often do you do the washing
like once a week yeah once a week or
maybe once or twice a week for me I hate
doing washing so I I will do anything I
can to delay doing the work that's my
favorite part
God's uh like very responsible but also
can't just you could just doesn't do
chores like you can tell yeah like is
always late to staff and he doesn't do
his chores I I hate doing what who likes
doing chores I like doing laundry I like
doing laundry so when you get that crisp
fresh laundry when you pull it out of
the washing machine it's like warm and
fresh and it smells good you've got the
right Fabrics off and everything because
to me I have I have a routine that I
like doing every day and if there's
something that I that I need to do that
breaks that routine which is normally
chores I hate it I hate it you're saying
I'm always like American Psycho
literally just describe
there's a routine I follow every day
every day
I just had to call you out yeah yeah
because to me when I'm doing chores the
only thing that's going through my mind
is [ __ ] can I because [ __ ] can I get
this over with childhood can I get this
over with as fast as possible so I can
go back to doing my normal [ __ ] and it's
just it to me I hate doing chores is
because it gets me away from what I
actually want to be doing which is uh
which is what I you know well what if
you know but what if for example right
like we don't live in a perfect world
where everything you do is something
that or everything you have to do is
something that you want to do right
sometimes you know you run into those
things where you're just like you know I
know I need to do this but right now I'm
just not kind of I'm not really in the
mood for it I know I have to do it
eventually but right now you know what I
don't really like it yeah I'll distract
myself and that's it's times like that
for me personally where I'm like I can
go do the washing
instances where I was like I would
rather do the washing right now than do
this thing but oh you so you're just
procrastinating
that's that's a successful progression
successful procrastination because it's
I'm replacing the thing that I have to
do with something I also have to do
anyway but I enjoy it more than what I
currently have to do
is that that's successful you are
fighting the evil with the evil is what
you're saying I'm fighting a greater
evil with a lesser evil
I if I'm going to do chores there needs
to be an indicator there needs to be a
line for me to be like okay God you need
to drop what you're doing and do the
chores otherwise I'm not gonna do it
unfortunately where does that line lie
for you
the line for you is all of my pants
smell like [ __ ] yes that is the line for
me wait but so do you do the laundry
then out of you in Sydney or is it well
mostly it's Sydney but when I'm with
when I'm by myself which you know now
that we've been traveling so often I've
had I've had to do laundry more often
than you know before before I was living
with Sydney that I had the same system
in place yeah uh because Sydney Sydney
likes doing the laundry
um I much prefer hoovering up and see I
hate hoovering up I hate I hate
vacuuming hoovering up I don't enjoy it
that's why I bought a Rumba I don't know
I don't enjoy it but it's way more
satisfying because when you get that
line and you see the crumbs all gone
you're like yeah yeah I'm doing this
Healthcare I eat a lot of food all right
bro sometimes the dust builds up
especially on tiled floors because my
house is tired floors the tiles shows
the dirt yeah you can you can really
really [ __ ] see all the dust and all
the little things that build up right
and it's just instant satisfaction
laundry you have to [ __ ] wait you
know you have to put all the [ __ ] in
laundry you have to wait for it to dry
and then it gets crisp and everything
like that with vacuuming it's just like
oh this is just instantly satisfying
isn't your laundry machine next to your
like shower or bath yes well then when I
when I like when when it's like laundry
day I just when I'm about to go in the
bath it's like full or whatever I just
take off my clothes put them in the
thing press laundry and then one by the
time I'm out of the bathtub it's dumb no
because what I what I because one I
don't take baths I take showers yes yes
I know I know but the reason I hate
laundry is not putting it in it's
because I always [ __ ] forget to take
it out yeah ADHD problems right I always
put in and I'm like I'm gonna come back
in an hour come back eight hours later
I've got to do laundry again because all
these clothes smell yeah and then repeat
that cycle basically I'm very I guess
I'm lucky that I'm literally like two
feet away from my thing so when it when
I'm working I hear
yeah and I'm like oh yeah all right also
my mine my laundry machine it washes and
then dries automatically I'm not that
really I'm not that privileged yeah see
because I had the same problem with my
old washing machine where it's like I
would throw it in and then I'd be like
I'll come back an hour later and it'll
be like the end of the day and I'm like
oh good I have to do this again I hate
how dryers make your clothes feel though
yeah I don't like Dr I don't like using
the dryer actually because it just makes
it all crinkly pull out I pull out my
t-shirt it's something like a [ __ ]
tissue yeah like a [ __ ] tissue it's like
I could snap it in half well no that's
why you got to use like fabric softeners
yeah yeah and then I also like ironing
as well so
what yeah I was going to say I was I'm
literally bottomed here I was literally
about to say on the chore tier list I
thought we would all agree that ironing
is like [ __ ] down there that's like
Zeds here no I like iron sometimes I
wish I was just like [ __ ] here
sometimes I wish I was like a box just
so I could [ __ ] instantly like I get
all the creases out of my clothes oh
there is though have you seen those
things what what like I think it's like
Panasonic or like Fujitsu or something
they've like made these like uh what do
we have so much dust on the sets so much
dusk where's it coming from someone
needs to Hoover up man
yeah I I also saw that as well but like
I think it's like Fujitsu Panasonic now
have these like uh there's like these
like electric cabinets where you
it looks like if you're trying to
Rebrand the Iron Maiden into like
something it looks like it looks like a
tiny sauna like a tiny one-room sauna
but you hang up your clothes oh yeah
this one is where you can like put your
body in it yeah yeah stuff like that and
it's like I legitimately thought about
this thing up top uh it's it's something
like that but it's like a full-on like
like is it loud It's my height is it
loud I don't know I've only ever seen
anything dude yeah no because I like I
only iron if I need to iron like
t-shirts you don't need to [ __ ] iron
teeth but you know like I have you know
when you want to wear like a nice
looking shirt or something that's when
you need to iron it because that's when
the crease is really really show yeah I
[ __ ] hate it I always I always iron
my shirts just before I go out oh
basically yeah well you know the the
Japanese business suits that they make a
lot of like non-iron ones what do you
mean they're like ones you don't need to
iron oh yeah yeah they're like not
increase but you can there's still
creases on them I've had them I've had
them I don't know like when I'm wearing
a suit you're you're making a commitment
wearing a suit shot and I kind of like
it needs to look good I know you're
wearing suits not often which is why I
don't iron often
yeah yeah yeah I don't know what what do
you like about ironing I think it's the
worst one I like ironing because it's
like I can just like kind of chill and
like not think while I'm doing it like
you know there's like a lot of people
who like you know do the dishes while
they watch TV and stuff like that or
yeah so like to me yeah like I don't
have to do it because I have a
dishwasher but like for me other people
yeah other people I used to have to do
that in my old place when I didn't have
a dishwasher but like for me now that's
been replaced with like ironing where
it's just like I don't have to think
about it and also you know it's like I
get to make the clothes I like wearing
look better than before so it's like I
don't know I don't know I I never used
to like ironing until recently I think
right because it now I just appreciate
it speed running middle age yeah because
like I think it's like now I appreciate
when my clothes look good yeah because I
remember when I was a kid you know I
always hated doing the chores and my
parents were like you'll get to an age
where you appreciate it you'll get to an
age
yeah yeah at first you know at first
they were telling me stories oh you know
when your cousin went to University
that's when he started enjoying cleaning
that's when he became a clean free
because he lived with a bunch of
University students that made him really
want to clean and they were waiting went
through the university stage didn't
change I was like don't worry when you
get a job and you live by yourself
that's when you appreciate it because
then you have to do it yeah live by
myself got a job didn't [ __ ] do it
and they were like well was your house
just like a mess huh was your house just
like the worst place on Earth it wasn't
like it wasn't the worst place on Earth
it was just I never enjoyed doing it so
I would only do it if roro yeah oh so
they said you would you would enjoy it
they said I would appreciate it and
started appreciate me
like like you're throwing your clothes
into the washing machine just stand
there be like damn because I appreciate
that they did it or I I think they
thought my quality standards would be a
lot higher than what they are they
thought that I would want to iron my
shirts every week and uh want to you
know do the washing and clean up every
week and I'm like I'll do it when I I
have like with all my chores I have a
certain threshold where I need to do it
otherwise it actually looks like a
[ __ ] dump and my threshold my
threshold to do my chores is like here
their threshold to do chores is like up
there right you know and they thought
that as I got older my threshold would
slowly slowly slowly catch up catch up
but as I've got older it's just stayed
exactly the same
today's episode is sponsored by Honey
the easy way to shop on your iPhone or
computer we shop online all of the
goddamn time and I need some coupon
codes to start saving some money damn
straight and thanks honey I can do just
that honey is the free shopping tool
that scales the internet for promo codes
and applies the best one it can find to
your cards John gentlemen gentlemen just
imagine this okay imagine this you are
shopping on one of your favorite sites
okay when you're a check out the honey
button appears and all you have to do is
Click apply coupons I'm doing that just
wait a few seconds wait a few seconds as
honey searches for coupons you can find
for that site and if honey does find a
working coupon bam oh prices dropped I
recently bought a cycling bag that was
very expensive and thanks to honey I
saved fifteen dollars off well honey
doesn't just work on your desktop
gentlemen it works on your iPhone as
well just activated on Safari on your
phone and Bam you can save on the go so
if you don't have honey you could be
straight up missing out on free savings
am I getting it you'll be doing yourself
a favor and supporting us as well so get
honey for free at joinhoney.com trash
taste that's joinhoney.com trash taste
back to the video you know the I don't
actually I'm not like that invested in
chores like in the arguments with it and
whatever what if you like chores
whatever I don't give a [ __ ] the one
thing that pisses me off is these people
who act like not using a dishwasher and
cleaning the plates makes you some kind
of like god tier Chad like have you seen
this online no people who are like bro I
use a dishwasher cringe dude clean it by
hand it gets it up better or like
parents and stuff we're like using the
dishwasher really it's like what do what
do you mean like that's just literally
what the dishwasher was yeah the
dishwasher the dishwasher makes so much
sense and it uses like one tenth the
amount of [ __ ] water why are you
still pretending like like getting in
there and wasting time wasting all this
[ __ ] water makes you some kind of
[ __ ] god-tier chat or something but
like no one says the same argument about
like cars right
driving laundry no nobody's like bro you
don't wash your lawn you'll close my
hand bro get the [ __ ] out of here bro
friends you just doesn't do it right
just doesn't do it the same way it's
like bro what the [ __ ] nah my hand
really gets the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of it
yeah I mean I get it back in the day duh
bro like dishwashers they they take a
lot of energy man and when when you're
trying to save costs and energy bills
you better be watching it by hand
water you're wasting it on Water I
believe like I
apparently is more cost effective to
wash my hands if not why wouldn't why
would everyone not get a dishwasher then
what because the dishwashing machine
itself is quite expensive yeah but if
you have it not using it as well not
every kitchen has enough space for a
dishwasher oh yeah true like a really
small dish like I'm pretty sure if you
own a dishwasher there's no benefit
except like maybe you have like a giant
pot that cannot be cleaned in the
dishwasher probably that makes sense
there's an argument for that but like
acting like it can't clean your plate
right are you kidding me like [ __ ] off
that's literally what I was invented for
I cleaned the plates argue with the best
out of any other type of thing that you
put in the dishwasher I don't know
people people get so [ __ ] I see so
many people online being like yeah man
dishwasher man this doesn't do it for me
I was like what do you mean what do you
mean yeah get another dishwasher I don't
know like they just enjoy doing the
dishes I can understand if you can't
afford a dishwasher or it's too much or
it doesn't fit like that those are all
valid reasons to not do it but when you
own one and you're like no no I'm like
it's to me to me dishwashers has always
been the machine that separates I guess
the more well-off to the people who
um
how can I word this the dishwasher has
always been like the big separator
between let's say the middle class and
the working class can I say that in
which countries globally or globally or
I don't know it's always been like in
like that in my mind but because like I
mean definitely in Japan I would say
yeah because I don't know like for some
reason everyone owns like a washing
machine right everyone owns a washing
machine you know that's that's just
standard but for some reason in my mind
whenever I went to a house and they had
a dishwasher I was like oh in the UK
yeah well in the UK I never I've never
had a dishwasher in the UK I don't know
anyway I don't know maybe this is my
privilege I don't think I ever went to
anyone's house who didn't have a dish
yes really yeah in Australia I think
everyone okay am I the weird one maybe
because I'm in the countryside and
there's just way more room like the
houses will definitely way bigger I
definitely feel that way in Japan right
because it's like until I went to my
friend's place and they had a dishwasher
I just thought the concept of
dishwashers didn't exist in Japan yeah
because every other house I was just
like oh there's the kitchen is so small
there's physically
your kitchen your house was really
[ __ ] small yeah yeah so that makes
sense why you wouldn't have one but like
even even going around friends places
and even going around families places
nobody it was rare for anyone I know to
have a dishwasher I wonder why because
I'm pretty sure the people in Brighton
generally make more money than well but
I think maybe what you get for the
houses like every kitchen I I'd ever
seen was like decently sized it was like
America sized but that's because all the
houses were [ __ ] oh no in in America
pretty much every house I've been to
yeah maybe it's just a kitchen size and
yeah okay well we have tons of room
because dishwashers that themselves
aren't as expensive like aren't that
expensive like compared to like uh but I
guess it's not as mandatory as like a
fridge and other [ __ ] yeah um I don't
know yeah dishwasher is when like your
your privileged enough to be able to pay
someone to wash your dishes for you you
know whereas Chloe washing clothing
that's that's a necessity you know no
one wants to wash their clothes by hand
that's weird isn't it could you look up
the savings the how much dishwashers
help or something yeah I'm pretty sure
you because I you know like the Eco Mode
on dishwashers yeah I'm pretty sure they
can like they can use an absurd amount
of like um a like a crazy little amount
of water to clean your dishes like a
really really really small amount yeah
like and it's like amazing but no one
ever does eco because everyone thinks
Eco [ __ ] that I do Nico do you yeah
you're the only person I know has ever
done this yeah I'm like I'm like full
blast on that why would you not use Eco
it's why wouldn't you I didn't even know
that wasn't like I I thought it would I
don't want my dishes to be less clean
that's what I thought what are you
talking it cleanse your dishes all the
same okay listen if I have an appliance
right I I have some advice maybe wash it
by hand
because on the machine I'm like it's
like do you want it to clean hard medium
or slowly and I'm like hard hard yeah
yeah I got a full blast on that [ __ ] I
want that [ __ ] to be clean no difference
in upbringing man I'm like yo I gotta
save everything
some things are just ingrained in my
mind okay wait where did you learn to
use Eco then so you said that you're
ingrained in your mind where are they
getting great
um uh restaurant so the only dishwasher
I've ever had is in the restaurant
because restaurant business because that
makes sense we need to own one so
obviously you gotta go Eco oh yeah yeah
this is the first time no I had a
dishwasher in my place in London and it
was the same kind of deal uh but yeah no
I that one didn't have a Eco this one
the one I have now does I think I don't
know if it's all in kanju I don't even
think my one has Eco I yeah I just press
start I don't I just press start because
I it's I open it up there's like eight
little eight different kanjis and I'm
like well I know when I press start and
go yeah it cleans it so I'm just not
gonna I just yeah I just go strong and
then start yeah see that's me in washing
machines even if it's in English all
right I look at all have some
information I'm sorry Kai yeah so if you
have a full load it is more efficient
and uh more cost efficient and energy
efficient but only if you have a full
version if you have a full load it's
more cost and energy efficient yeah so
if it's just like
you do not have a full load every time I
put far too much in that's my problem is
that I I literally try and Tetris it and
then what I I'm an idiot because then I
pull it out and half the [ __ ] isn't
[ __ ] clean because I like quadruple
stuff because it's like way too close to
each other yeah how big is your
dishwasher tiny oh okay yeah it's tiny
Japanese ones are tiny I have I have one
that comes out of my thing and it's
maybe like uh because the the US the one
I had we had in the UK was [ __ ]
stupid I I it's probably normal US size
massive I think it's like a half or a
third I think I think it's like about
that big yeah maybe maybe it's a half or
a third yeah not that that deep so yeah
if you have a meal you know like let's
say you I don't know you've had like
lunch and dinner yeah four plates a
bunch of side maybe you had soup with it
the classes like that'll fill it up yeah
because I've run out of place Cutlery
between just the two of us before the
dishwasher becomes full my dishwasher
Can Only Hold like uh like fives plates
oh okay and then it can hold some
flashes and then maybe a few other
little things it's not it's not a lot
yeah my dishwasher is massive yeah
you've got an American sized one yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think that's because I
think I prefer having my size though no
I do I would as well because that would
the dishwasher I have right now because
it's built into my house it's way too
big for just two people okay right the
only time I actually feel we get like
value out of it is when we have like a
party or whatever yeah it's pretty
Perfect by the time I've got after a few
days it's pretty full and yeah easy I
like it because I hated doing dishes in
my old place in Japan [ __ ] hated it
sucks I I mean I hate doing chores so I
always hate doing dishes then you you
like leave them in a dry for a little
while and then like the water didn't dry
properly and it stains the glass it
looks disgusting someone sneeze in your
glass and you're like I like the residue
yeah yeah
I should have dried it but I don't use a
towel because sometimes the towel leaves
like little stains you know not stains
but like it like the marks yeah
dishwasher is great yeah that's that's
why you've got to like hand dry your
glasses if you don't want the stains no
I did I used to but then you maybe the
towel would like streak it or something
and then you're like I'm gonna kill
myself yeah get some advice use your
hands
that was what it was when I was using my
hands okay there's no winning okay your
monkey hands I don't have my privilege
for now for this part uh I I had a a the
first time it's ever happened to me in
drowned right I had this place next to
my house where I used to always go to
get coffee and sandwiches like fresh
bread is that the one you took me to do
yeah maybe yeah it's amazing yeah and I
I went the other day and it was it was
closed during a normal day I was like
that's weird I went back in the next day
it's closed again I'm like oh yeah all
right what's going on here yeah I go
back yesterday it's gone like they they
were building [ __ ] in it and I was like
what oh no I was like I I I am I not
supporting local businesses I've been
here so many times I I literally like I
must have given them more money than any
other customer potentially I won't hit
like every [ __ ] day right and I was
like how do I what do I do now should
have brought two sandwiches a day I I
did I literally did I die I bought two
every time I went and a coffee even
though the coffee was [ __ ] and
overpriced I bought it from there damn
you were the only person yeah the only
the only one in your neighborhood
uh it's a really nice coffee store and
they talk to me every time I go but it's
really so awkward small talk but I can
tell for Japan it's like super sincere
yeah yeah this is like if you know you
know it's sincere when a random Japanese
person is talking to another random
person yeah and a foreigner on top of
that it's like bro is it a family-owned
coffee I don't know I feel like it is
I've never heard of this it being a
chain or anything yeah and they have
it's nice they're really cute they they
always ask what I'm doing that day and I
always answer the same thing yeah but
they ask any day and then one time I was
carrying like some camera gear and
they're like oh you filming today I'm
like yeah
yeah it's really cute they're really
nice and they do good coffee so now I'm
gonna go have to go there a bunch and
buy their a little overpriced coffee buy
their stocks it's a little overpriced
but you get like the good experience you
get the people who actually care about
their jobs there's nothing like yeah
there's nothing that brings us smile to
me more than just seeing someone that
just really loves and cares for their
job even if it's like the small jobs you
know I'd rather give them pay a little
bit extra than Starbucks to say [ __ ] you
to Starbucks but yeah here's the thing
right then I talk about this on the
podcast last time no I didn't I rant it
to someone else I'm just trying to
trying to remember who I've ranted to
about what yeah but I've definitely
ranted about this okay I I don't want to
always order [ __ ] from Starbucks right
but online I in the morning I I might
want a coffee and I want food with it
right because I want lunch yeah so I
want coffee and a lunch yeah and like
nowhere in Japan does decent coffee and
decent lunch it's like pick up pick your
pick your priority do you want good
coffee okay the lunch is probably gonna
be really bad or they won't have
anything yeah do you want good lunch
okay they probably don't have coffee and
if they do it's like just black
Americana yeah and then they give you
some like sugar packets and stuff I want
uh usually it's like sour as well yeah
this is privileged by the way this is
privileged the conversation but um like
Starbucks is like the only place that
does it yeah well on ubereats so I'm
like
I don't want to buy Starbucks but
they're the only one who does it if a
competitor comes up and it's a smaller
person I swear to God I'll give you all
my money just please someone else yeah
well I'll tell you the thing that annoys
me about ordering stuff from Starbucks
here in Japan uh especially now after
going to America and having the
privilege of ordering Starbucks and
coffee in America especially la which is
oh my God the amount of options you get
in America just blows Japan out the
water right yeah like Japan have like
the bare basic options with all of their
coffee I would expect this like most
most of the most the options I don't
really give a [ __ ] about but in Japan
the really thing the big option that
really annoys me and that's why the
reason I've already ordered coffee from
Starbucks is because I want a hot coffee
even if it's like the summer most of the
time I want a hot coffee in Starbucks in
Starbucks you can only order one size on
ubereats I don't know why that is oh
really yeah if you try to order hot
coffee in Starbucks like the latte or
something every hot coffee there's no
size option it's only one size and it's
the smaller size and I'm like and it's
Japan's small size as well so it's not
it's no way a decent size which is
basically an espresso yeah yeah but for
some reason the rice latte they're iced
coffee it's it's got ordered like the
tall brande venti size but the hot
coffee has only one size and I'm like
why is that the case what is going on
Starbucks in Japan and then and then
like the dichotomy of spending a month
in [ __ ] LA or whatever you go on the
ubereats app and the thing is like a
[ __ ] character customization series
holy [ __ ] there's every option possible
oh yeah that was that was dumb yeah you
just wanted one coffee and you have nine
options if you choose each one you're
like what the [ __ ] yeah the moment you
choose either hot or cold it opens to
another page
like what molecular level of milk do you
want yeah tell us tell us the atomic the
atomic weight of the milk it's like what
do you mean but yeah but all of breeds
customization is [ __ ] in Japan like if
you want to get like actually stuff like
customized like like I think we said
before if you order Subway in Japan okay
one you shouldn't be doing that yeah but
if you do because I just want a sandwich
you're a sub right yeah you can't order
toasted online yes you if you order a
Subway sandwich you cannot get it
toasted you have to go to the store
which to me it's like what is the
barrier here like are you worried that
it'll be like soggy when it gets to me
I'm I'm okay to sign up for that risk
like I I want the cheese melted like I I
don't care I'll heat it up myself or
some [ __ ] I don't know but maybe you're
The Rare Breed and most Japanese people
are just like nah well I think because
they don't know it's like an option
because no one goes to Subway here yeah
that's true sandwich is a cold yeah I've
only seen like one Subway here in Tokyo
or something like that yeah there's not
many at all no it's not like uh because
why would you [ __ ] hood for it so
it's really bad it's really not great
it's really bad it's not great yeah I
will admit like it's it's not great in
America but it leaks better than the one
yeah here like even McDonald's as well
like the one thing I want from
McDonald's with my [ __ ] meal
sometimes is McFlurry and there's only
one McFlurry here there's only one
option McFlurry I see Oreo McFlurry and
that's the worst [ __ ] McFlurry out of
every option you could possibly choose
Japan choose to put the Oreo McFlurry on
ubereats am I the only one who thinks
Oreos taste bad I just think audios
Oreos don't taste good I just think they
the biscuit is [ __ ] quality yeah and the
stuff is the only thing keeping it
together yeah literally and
metaphorically I mean it doesn't like
make me you know [ __ ] juice
it's such a mid cookie I think it's
below mid there are mood cookies tim
tams are mid yeah like [ __ ] off
I just think that like Oreos are way
below that yeah I think that the per the
best McFlurry is just just give me the
[ __ ] one with the little chocolate
like crushed sprinkles in it like you
know where they just do a piece of
chocolate I think I've ordered a
McFlurry maybe twice in my life I like
it in the UK a lot so I don't I have no
say on this yeah in the UK it goes hard
really I think so well the problem with
like Oreo McFlurries is that unlike say
some other chocolate bits where it's
actually like physical like nice solid
bits of chocolate or honey cookies or
whatever the Oreo McFlurry is just like
the cookie just turns into [ __ ]
powder right right so so the the powder
just Blends in with the ice cream and
I'm like this is awful because I want
like I there's no clear distinction
between where the ice cream starts and
where the cookie starts you know because
it's just ice cream cookie now at this
point I think you're expecting a little
too much high quality from something
from McDonald's
McFlurries are normally pretty damn good
yeah if it works yeah right anything but
Oreo mcflurry's [ __ ] slabs what are
the other what's your favorite woman I
just I'm basic I like the dairy milk
option yeah yeah yeah dairy milk yeah
dairy milk it's just like bits of dairy
milk it's more than crunchy the crunchy
the crunchy option or this or the m m
options those all great all fantastic m
m one out of the two times I ever
ordered McFlurry that was pretty good
yeah but Oreo mcflurry's why Japan why
why why are you why why would you choose
Oreo hey at least the machine always
works here I've never been to McDonald's
it wasn't working yet that's true I
didn't I didn't know that's true that's
true that's that's we got it good we got
it good that's the trade-off is it is it
is it a trade that's like that's like
the monkey portrait yes your ice cream
machines always work but you can order
only you'll get the worst one but you
can only order Oreo McFlurries I'm like
this is this is hell no this is [ __ ]
hell the ultimate choice that had the uh
the the MC3 with the Black Thunder uh
Black Thunder yeah those are really good
I see like I don't know do you like
black Thunder I actually really like
that what's Black Thunder yeah like
thunder is like those like Japanese yeah
like chocolate bars it's kind of like a
crunchy yeah okay no it's not is it not
no let me let me Google this right now
no no because like they have more
options in McDonald's itself
yeah I don't know if they still do it
was definitely I don't know it's a it's
it's a chocolate bar if you come to
Japan you should try it's pretty good
and if you go to Hokkaido they have a
white chocolate version yeah but they
don't call it white Thunder they call it
white oh this
yeah
I never understood that
oh yeah this is this [ __ ] slaps yeah
that's a good chocolate bar it's pretty
good I I I don't eat a lot of Japanese
chocolate bars because I noticed that in
Japan I feel like uh
they just make chocolate bars that taste
good and then they worry about what's in
it after because like every single
chocolate bar you look at the packaging
like Oh my Jesus Christ when you read
the like the nutritional information
yeah yeah it's like they'll have like 50
grams of sugar or something like who we
can play about Coke cans Japan's what
I don't know it should be posting
how often do you eat black Thunder no I
don't but okay in my mind right I I
don't care about like a lot of the time
if I want to [ __ ] talk about I don't
care about the calorie count but
sometimes you're in that mood where I'm
like I want chocolate but I also want to
not kill myself so and is this thing
tasting is this thing going to taste so
good that it's worth putting this in my
body right so it's kind of like a
toss-up yeah and a lot of the time in
Japan weirdly there's just a lot of
chocolate bars of snacks that are just
absolutely rammed with like carbs and
sugars like way more than normal stuff
oh yeah I don't know if you've noticed
this yeah no you should you should pick
them up have a look and just compare
them to some chocolates that we have or
other American ones but they probably
put another God knows what chemicals are
I mean either way I rarely eat sweets so
yeah I just don't [ __ ] with it yeah I
should give me a [ __ ] sandwich
like if I'm hungry I'll just eat a
sandwich no for somebody like for me I
rarely eat chocolate bars because if I
want something sweet I want like a nice
like a fridge yeah a premium one like a
rich cake or really nice ice cream or
some something that's gonna like you
know fill that uh feel that desire for
me but that's why I mean I mean that's
why I've already eat desserts I think
because I've rarely get into the mood to
eat something sweet oh we had this
conversation like yeah a couple weeks
ago but yeah yeah what's what's your
favorite chocolate bar
do we have to do like a chocolate bar
too okay I'm gonna be honest upstairs
right now I know it's not chocolate but
I like white chocolate the most and I
know it's awful for you as well it
tastes so good though really yeah white
chocolate is probably my least favorite
it's just pure sugar like at least
chocolate has something in it yeah white
chocolate is just sugar it's nothing
it's not even chocolate I like the cocoa
I like that I think I think dark
chocolate is my favorite I'm gonna go
milk chocolate
no no if you were to just have it by
itself are you talking about brands or
are you just talking about white dark or
well I mean brands or whatever because
it like it's hard to choose a brand
because I don't think it's fair to like
compare Toblerone yay or nay yay that's
that's that's CA yeah yeah yeah yeah I
mean like I don't think it's fair to
compare say dairy milk to Lindor or
Ferrero Russia
are we just talking about the Bare Bones
Five Guys to internet you know just not
not fair they're a different price
we do that why are you we did that we're
guilty of that yeah yeah we did do that
to me it's different because that's
let's save this for the America Tour
okay save this for the America Tour I
don't really feel like arguing about
Burgers I'm I've got chocolate now do
you still want to continue the chocolate
debate yeah yeah I mean I just oh Joey
asked the question I have a loaded topic
next after the chocolates
I'm not ready but
one of my favorites is yeah I mean dairy
milk I I've grown an appreciation of
dairy milk after moving out of England
yeah I think British chocolates are
actually really really [ __ ] good when
you take one bite of Hershey's you're
like oh
oh this is disgusting it kind of yeah
it's just horrible I don't know why like
Hershey's to me always it it kind of
tastes like farts I don't know why like
it tastes gas I think it had to do with
uh too right so I think World War II
yeah when obviously where they were
rationing everything I think
I think the UK and some other European
countries just decided to just make less
chocolate because they were like yeah
we're not gonna make this and whereas I
think America wanted to give a lot of
the troops chocolate I could be wrong
remember can you fact check this okay
but yeah it's something along those
lines where they wanted to keep giving
chocolates people because you know it's
a little good morale booster it's like
made chocolate that had a lot less
chocolate a lot less milk
because you know it takes a lot of milk
and a lot less cocoa uh cocoa cacao
cacao um and so they ended up making
this kind of like weird sugary [ __ ]
mess and uh yeah and then they were
making it all throughout the war
Hershey's so yeah so people are still
eating Hershey's and they make fun of
British people for eating War ration
like food [ __ ] In America still
eating War rations dude and it's like
their favorite chocolate bar it just
doesn't taste good it doesn't it doesn't
taste like chocolate no and it's so
obvious that if you eat any chocolate
from Europe yeah and then you go to
America and you have American chocolate
you're like this isn't chocolate what is
this this is like even any million sore
chocolate tasted it and was like I will
replicate this and formulate but I think
even Asian chocolates aren't that good
like the Bare Bones basic chocolate bars
you can't get good chocolate here yeah
but if you're just talking about here's
this some of the cheapest options you
can [ __ ] get a lot of Asian
chocolates are just missing that like
the weight the the heaviness that you
get in European chocolates I feel like a
like a Frodo bar is like better than
pretty much all that Frodo is it from is
it
I believe
I know
hey soprano can you make a can you Bob
that's just shaped like Frodo from Lord
of the Rings
I'm more of a gimla guy okay
yeah like Photo bars are like the better
than basically any kind of cheap
chocolate you can get in Asia I think
yeah yeah I based that on Japan and
Thailand yeah that's the reason I don't
get chocolate bars here because there's
nothing that really fills that like that
makes me get like feels that
satisfaction for me I think it's just a
culture thing right like they just don't
have a history and a big culture of
making chocolate as long as I say Europe
yeah yeah I mean they they have a they
obviously made chocolate but you know
yeah because a lot of Japan has a lot of
its own type of sweets right
give us some knowledge yeah
soldiers during World War II
to a pep up yeah
yeah cool so yeah I was kind of right
yeah yes nice
wow wrong I don't know okay I might have
been wrong on the makeup of what goes
into Hershey's but I'm pretty sure it's
like less chocolate yeah from a Johnny
Harris videos
thank you Vox
all right what was your [ __ ]
pre-loaded argument
yeah sure all right okay also before we
leave the chocolate debate and sweets
Japan's sweets kind of lame not gonna
lie just saying yeah it depends do you
want beans
[Laughter]
no it's like there's there's more
variety than just [ __ ] choc because I
know you I know you you want one type of
dessert and it's like either [ __ ] ice
cream or chocolate yeah yeah you're like
anything else anything else disgusting I
cannot imagine why any cakes cakes who
the [ __ ] eats beans for dessert ew
disgusting it was like I can't imagine
why any other culture would want to eat
anything else that's sweet
chocolate and ice cream unfathomable we
should start colonizing these places and
show them what a real dessert okay
um completely off topic while I
remembered that I watched it I watched
um I watched the new Storm movie oh
people love my movie reviews oh my God
here we go is this the loaded topic Is
This Love and thunder right yeah oh [ __ ]
yeah I've heard it was [ __ ] it was
seriously awful
well I I never gone to a Marvel movie
before this this badly and felt like I
literally just watched a filler I just
watched filler yeah I don't know what
the [ __ ] and these [ __ ] online
will be like no no you have to watch
this because you need to know that that
Thor uh X happened because this is gonna
happen in the next movie and it's like
bro this could have been a cliff notes
this did not matter at all yeah who
cares who it's West
who who who you're such a bad movie I
don't think that's a hot take though
I've seen a lot of people talk about the
new Thor movie and just say it was bad
well not bad video just very very
mediocre kind of was wasn't even a
Marvel movie it was like a comedy movie
that's what I heard I'm gonna start
raiding all the movies that we talk
about on the show four out of 3.5 out of
10. oh that low what five would be meh I
actually felt like I wasted my time wow
and I rarely feel like that about movies
yeah because you you said the Multiverse
of Madness was [ __ ] oh it's like a five
that was a five
because I watched it afterwards
um and I didn't go to see it in cinemas
because because of Conor's raging review
for us I was like I don't need to watch
this in cinemas and then I watched it uh
when it came out and uh came out on
stream platforms I thought it was okay
not as bad as like what you were making
out to be I think I think I'm just way
more invested in the whole Marvel
Cinematic Universe than you are and I
think Marvel was got to a point now
where it's just basically a [ __ ]
anime at this point you know marvel the
m MCU is the Western anime okay it's the
Western equivalent of anime right yeah
yeah I mean I don't know it's just it's
again it's so I don't know it's so
boring now like after end game I feel
like they've just been stumbling right
again to find something and they're
building up these this weird stuff and
she feels like who who cares no I think
I think because they I think I think
Marvel's going through two problems
right now one is like end game happened
and they've obviously when you've had 10
years worth of build up into like one
[ __ ] film or two films obviously
you're not gonna be able to follow that
up immediately
um and the second thing is that there's
just too many [ __ ] things right now
because I think they've just how do you
keep up with it yeah because I think
they just announced all of the films in
Phase five and the end of phase six as
well which is going to be like the next
Avengers right the next the next the
next two Avengers film is going to be
all the way in phase six now yeah
um and I I believe there are more films
coming out in one year than there is in
the entirety of phase one of MCU and
like how how are you meant to [ __ ]
keep up with that you know yeah I I mean
it's just a lot and a lot of the time I
wouldn't mind if I felt like I was
getting good movies but a lot of them
are just kind of like all right you're
just putting stuff out yeah it's like
it's like it's just it's just quantity
over quality yeah yeah I don't know and
uh yeah and it's like I I watched um I
watched Top Gun the new one that was
really good I heard that was really good
I watched it in four mxd that she was so
good yeah because the chairs were like
moving around yeah with the Jets it was
so good I mean it was just a good movie
like it was just great like it didn't
try to do anything wild it was just like
let's just tell a story and it's fun and
it's good and apparently that was like
barely any CG in it either
it was like really impressive yeah the
shots were so good yeah eight out of ten
it was kind of eight out of ten honestly
it was it was fun if you haven't watched
it I think it's still in Japanese
Cinemas you should go watch it it's
really fun I had I had a similar thing
with you where uh I I finally watched
the new Robert Patterson Batman movie as
well I love his raging reviews
but I like I like Robert Pattinson oh I
do I do too but I thought that movie was
boring as [ __ ] I thought it was okay I
was just it was okay he was just too emo
he was it was like it was like if Bruce
Wayne listened to a little bit too much
My Chemical Romance you know I wanted
Robin Paxton to be in the movie more as
him
I did too I did as well but my God it
was just like every time every time he
went on screen I could [ __ ] hear
Boulevard of Broken Dreams just like in
the [ __ ] background the father killed
me was when he took the mask off and he
has eyeliner did you just come back from
a concert like to help hide his eyes
Okay the mask is Welcome to the Black
Parade when he took off the mask I was
like you are so emo it's just hilarious
this is the covers the color of his skin
right yes oh my God I liked it it wasn't
too long yes it was too long yeah it was
far too long and the thing is I just
didn't think Batman as a character was
an interesting character I liked I
thought he was more interesting in in
this movie than he was at Batman
really I because I really really like
the Christian Bell Batman yeah but I
like him at the Dark Knight at the
Batman Begins I didn't really I wasn't
really invested in it I thought
I I did because at least you got to see
like a character Arc in in Batman Begins
it wasn't as interesting as Dark Knight
I actually think he was a like Christian
Bell was a more interesting character as
Batman in Batman Begins versus The Dark
Knight where he was mostly about the
Joker right but in the Batman I thought
it started the same way it ended in my
opinion where it's like Rob Patterson is
sad at the beginning of the movie and
he's just even more sad yeah because
he's broken he's like a [ __ ] up
character because he's Batman who he's a
[ __ ] psychopath yeah but like it's
like he's not supposed to be cool this
guy's a freak yeah but like they I think
they made it a little bit too on the
nose with this movie whereas like you
know with the Christian Bale ones it's
like yeah he's a little bit [ __ ] up
but it's a little more subtle
I feel whereas like this one well like
especially with the [ __ ] eyeliner I
was just like all right I get it I like
that Batman big boohoo I I really liked
the Riddler in the Batman like yeah I
thought he was a really really good
villain yeah but I mean we're comparing
it to the Jim Carrey version
in terms of like Batman villains and
just superheroes right and in general I
think it was a really really good
villain I think like the Batman was much
less of an interesting character versus
The Riddler in this film uh because I
didn't really get a reason to really
care about Christian uh sorry not
Christians character I didn't really I
didn't really have a reason to care
about the Batman in this film the last
hour was just far too long as well like
it was just drag it was it was I'll
admit that yeah I'm just a champion yeah
don't get me wrong I love Rob Pattinson
and like his acting was good but like he
had far too little lines that were even
interesting yeah I'm hoping that the
next one is like you know because we
have Batman Begins I hope it's kind of
obsidianity a little bit more hopefully
Dark Knight but it won't be that good
but because if it felt it felt like with
the Batman it just came in with with the
assumption that like the audience like
you know Batman we don't need to explain
Batman you already know his character
who knows Batman yeah but like to me I I
still I still want to see that character
I still want a reason to care about you
want to kill your [ __ ] dad die again
I mean sure no not again yeah every
every God there's so many of them I hate
it I did like though the fact that like
the Riddler they just made him out to be
like a 4chan yeah but it's great that's
great
what made it interesting is that they
took an old villain and they made it
like they modernized him you know they
made it relevant they made a current you
know same thing with what they did with
the Joker with that movie uh with the
recent movie that came out as well I
just thought with the Batman Batman was
just the most boring character out of
everyone in that cast for me because he
was barely he barely had any [ __ ]
lies to begin with for me it's like one
of the there's a lot of really
interesting Dynamics in the Batman I
again it's been like a long time since I
watched it but I really like I really
like the fact that how he was like even
the police saw him as this kind of
weirdo and they were like no no what are
you doing get out of here yeah and then
obviously the one uh the warden one yeah
the warden was helping him but then
everyone else was like commissioner the
commissioner sorry yeah Gordon
uh yeah Gordon was like you know the
only one helping him and I thought that
was interesting because in real life why
the [ __ ] with this random psychopath in
a suit be allowed to like go into the
scene of the crime yeah and it's like it
does it would make sense right I liked
how it felt a bit more real a bit more
gritty I liked it I thought it was good
um but yeah I I what was it what would
you ran out of ten the Batman
oh seven point five eight and that's
that's the Conor movie okay monkey
reviews
Sonic 2 on a plane how was that it was
exactly the same as Sonic one but with
knuckles
I are they real and they announced Sonic
three didn't they yeah which is has
Shadows yeah I enjoyed Sonic 2 way more
than I thought I would it was fun yeah
it was it was a good time I think that
I'm okay with this being a series I
think it's just fun enough where I I
think it's fine it's straddled the
perfect line between campy and cringe
there was so much cringe jokes in it
there there was but they they [ __ ]
they they owned it you know they owned
it you know they it wasn't that's like
Sonic's ammo though yeah yeah it's like
it's not Sonic
drives in general right yeah like they
they got the essence of Sonic in this
film and so I I went into it and I saw
like one or two jokes I'm like it's
gonna be an awful film yeah but I kept
watching I'm like this is an awful film
but I'm [ __ ] having a great time was
really good as well
Jim Carrey's great yeah Jim Carrey's
just [ __ ] great yeah and I think the
scene that sold me was
um the dance battle
I was like oh I end wait what is it it's
just [ __ ] like they're like you close
uh [ __ ] siberius yeah they're in
Siberia or some [ __ ] and they're in this
random bar and they piss off this random
[ __ ] Russian guy or some [ __ ] and you
think a fight's gonna go down and then
like he takes off his shirts and starts
dancing and they have a dance battle and
I'm like this is so stupid that it's
like just [ __ ] loot around and become
amazing
oh my God
that's that's the thing that's the thing
it's it's straddles the perfect line
between cringe and campy and it it's
just it just it's it it straddles it so
well though just it's just entertaining
all right you're not meant to take it
seriously hoping the next one's good
with Shadow it's rerun it is it did you
see oh no it is yeah yeah I'm hoping
it's gonna be good yeah yeah [ __ ]
Edge Lord Shadow I can't wait to see
I can't wait to see [ __ ] I can't wait
for all the edgy [ __ ] Shadow jokes yo
Robert Pattinson good like yeah
surprising is rollers yes
okay I'd be down for that I'd be down
I'd give the Sonic movie uh if Shadow
isn't wearing eyeliner
I think I have more fun watching the
Sonic movie even though it was [ __ ] than
I did watching the last two Marvel
movies so I'll give it a six yeah I'm
not surprised with that yeah I mean
Marvel to me I'm I'm only I only like it
because I'm invested in what happens if
you're not investing what happens you're
gonna hate the recent Marvel movies
because there's literally like no reason
to watch it that's what I feel like it's
it's just objectively bad like if the
only way that you can enjoy Marvel is
that you've been you are dedicated to
the Marvel Universe yeah then like the
movies aren't good movies should be able
to hold up on its own I totally agree
with you like the most interesting thing
for Doctor Strange for me uh was seeing
his progression as a character and
seeing how this affects the wider
Universe of Marvel I fully [ __ ] admit
that and I fully [ __ ] admit there's
there's so many moments in Multiverse
Multiverse with Madness that just
doesn't work as a standalone movie yeah
like the moment you talked about where
it's just like oh look at these
characters care about these characters
because he's just turned into fan
service yeah it's it's literally fans it
was like there was so much fan service
in that movie uh um I don't feel like
Doctor Strange as a character has like
in that movie actually gets anything out
of it like does he doesn't change at all
like in the first movie it's great
because like he's having to learn it all
and he's having to change his like
assholish ways yeah but then he just
becomes better that Cumberbatch yeah and
then he just hasn't changed at all or
like progressed in any way like at least
Thor has changed a [ __ ] tone as a
character and it's somewhat interesting
to follow but like I just find Doctor
Strange really boring to watch because
Benedict Cumberbatch has just been
playing Sherlock but with magic like the
past two movies or three movies I don't
know what the [ __ ] it's so boring yeah
if there's one thing I do actually
recommend Loki is probably the best
thing to come out I can imagine Loki
could be good Loki is one an interesting
story two it's kind of self it's kind of
like self-contained so it tells a
self-contained story
um and three they make Loki's character
super super [ __ ] interesting okay
it's it's he's always been one of the
more interesting characters yeah exactly
he's been one of the more interesting
characters and they gave him such an
interesting character Arc and character
progression as well where they didn't
exactly change his character at all they
just gave him way more depth like highly
[ __ ] recommend Loki it kind of hits
all the boxes you want from what Marvel
kind of used to be before end game it's
an interesting story it really really
affects the wider Universe
um and it's just but you can enjoy a
standalone as well [ __ ] amazing watch
Loki probably I'm recommending movies
now I watched also on on the plane I
watched The Big Lebowski that was good
[ __ ] fantastic first time I've ever
watched it yeah that's amazing movie
such a good fun movie such a fun movie I
I recently watched a movie uh I don't
know if it's new at all but like hockey
recommended it to me it's called
Greenland you know this movie no it's so
familiar it's a country yeah like like
name does the country but it's like it's
basically the most I would say out of
all of like the the world is ending like
apocalyptic movies it's probably one of
the most realistic like representations
of it so it's like it's basically just
like uh the world there's this giant
meteor uh or Comet or whatever it is
that's like flying around the earth and
it's about and like little bits of its
debris is about to hit the Earth but
it's Gerald Butler yeah yeah oh yeah
hell yeah it's just disaster movies now
yeah I think it's like his production
company I think so literally all he
makes is disaster yeah but it's him and
it's like you know like little bits of
uh comments are gonna like hit the earth
and then there's one big part of the
comment where it's like it's bigger than
the asteroid that killed the dinosaurs
and you know the Earth has 48 hours left
and it's basically like Gerard Butler
plays like this dad who just does
everything he can to try and get his
family to this safety bunker in the
middle of Greenland yeah and it's like
and I I personally enjoyed it because it
made me super [ __ ] anxious the entire
time because like they go through these
like really it like I think it perfectly
shows what would actually happen it's
basically because it's like based in the
US most of the time what would actually
happen if a situation like that happened
in the real world right so it's like you
know uh Gerard Butler's like family gets
like selected to like you know go you
know because he he's like his uh his
character plays like a construction
worker or something right so it's like
they pick out all the people with like
the important occupations that would be
you know responsible for rebuilding
Society once the Earth gets destroyed
yeah yeah um and then it's like all this
like [ __ ] about like people being like
desperate to like [ __ ] steal the QR
code and stuff like that so that they
can get on the plane and it's like it's
[ __ ] like anxiety driving the entire
time that sounds pretty interesting I
like Jared Butler as an actor I wish
that he did something
yeah yeah I mean I remember when he was
one of the hottest names in Hollywood
you know 300 right yeah after 300 after
300 yeah like the man crush that
everyone had no included how couldn't
you how could abs of steel sexy [ __ ]
math yeah we'll see what was the other
Apocalypse movie that recently came out
not recently but came out a while ago on
Netflix I'd like Leonardo I don't know I
heard that sucked I heard I heard that
sucked I watched it yeah what was bad
about what's bad about it one it was
like [ __ ] three hours long and
there's just like dumb [ __ ] edits in
the movie that are fourth wall breaking
they're so frustrating yeah and it's
just like it's it's like a political
satire of what's Happening real like now
in the world but I feel like satire is
so like funny and unfunny at the same
time and it's just like it's really
grating well because I saw the one scene
that came from that show that was spread
around recently because it was like so
you talk about political satire but in
that case it must have been it was so
damn good satire it was so on the nose
so I believe there's a scene where they
try to warn everyone about the income
the incoming asteroid right on the news
the news is just like we don't do that
here let's let's talk about let's talk
about something nice let's we're here
for Good Vibes right right and then I
believe recently in the UK in the UK got
[ __ ] come on come on come on guys
come on come on guys we're better than
this but in the UK there was a recent
interview
uh that was about the impending heat
wave that Europe's currently going
through yeah yeah where it is a
record-breaking Heat Wave I believe now
the heat waves pass but UK recorded a
new record high for the highest
temperature ever recorded in in our
country 47 which is like 40 or 41
degrees Yeah which is which is insane
for a country without air conditioning
and for houses that are built to trap
heat that is [ __ ] excruciating that
is dangerous people legitimately die
from heat stroke and [ __ ] from this you
know this is this has gone beyond it oh
it's it's a bit hot you know it's a bit
hot and people like oh back when I'm
from back when I'm from uh you know it's
5 000 degrees where I'm from I was born
on the surface of the Sun I'll have you
know I [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] but yeah
so this uh weather expert was trying to
warn the interview on the news that you
know we should prepare for hard times
because you shouldn't take care of
yourself people are going to die from
this event events and the newscaster
literally said you know you're all you
whether all you meteorologists are so
you know you're so down like why are you
such downers all the time
good weather how could you complain
about a bit of heat a bit of sunshine
and it was just it was so on the nose to
what to the scene that's the uh the
other film yeah the other film kind of
portrayed that it's it was it was kind
of like depressingly
depressingly accurate like I said it was
it was
very funny at times and very cringy
times like some of the fact that I was
very good and it was tasteful and others
were very like oh but again I guess it
could be with your political leaning as
well yeah like if you're you know you
might find one it was trying to make fun
of both sides yeah but at times just
made it looked made it seem like dumb
right and there's this whole kind of
yeah there's like a subtle art to doing
that kind of stuff I don't know for me
it was just South Park's like the uh
kind of like King at that right like if
it's too on the nose then it's just like
all right all right we get it yeah I
haven't watched South Park up late
though I don't know if it's good I don't
know if it's good but back when I used
to watch style Park you know that was
very funny yeah they were like kind of
like the kings are being able to make
both sides look stupid while also just
making a funny funny show in general as
well yeah I think they've definitely
done done some episodes there yeah were
bad but oh yeah I'm sure and what sure
doesn't yeah on the titties underrated
foreign
going back to Top Gun though I've
definitely grown more of an appreciation
to any action films with Tom Cruise in
them just because have you guys been
like been recommended the clips and the
shorts that are just basically a bunch
of Tom Cruise interviews describing all
the stunts that he's done no bro that
man Tom Cruise as we know is [ __ ]
insane right but he's the right kind of
insane to make amazing action movies
right right because he is very like old
school when it comes to stunts and
everything like that how do you do all
of his stunts right now he does I don't
know if he does all of them but a lot of
them he does by himself so one of the
craziest stunts I haven't even seen the
movie but one of the craziest stunts
I've heard
um him talk about recently was in one of
the recent Mission Impossible movies
they do like a Halo jump
uh and what's a Halo jump that it's
where you like jump from like the
stratosphere I think yeah yes I believe
it's like okay can we fact check exactly
what a Halo jump is
um but basically it's a Skydive it's
it's a Skydive skydive from space it's a
skydive from space right see we're not I
don't know if it's from space but it's a
it's either a very low or very high
skydive I'm gonna guess very high right
a very low would just be a fall
I meant either a low out shoe than usual
or higher out to you I think it's higher
uh well Halo stands for high altitude
low openings okay
[Music]
yeah right from the stratosphere right
I'm pretty sure or it's like above the
stratosphere or something anyway it's a
really high score yeah so in this movie
because after him after watching him
talk about it I actually went out and
watched the scene in this movie and it's
it's one long shot right it's one
[ __ ] long shot of them jumping out of
the airplane and then there's this
there's this in entire [ __ ] action
sequence that happens mid-air and it's
all done like IRL in real life where
what about IRL stands for yeah yeah
I just just in case the viewers in
though okay well one of one of the guys
gets like struck by lightning that's
obviously CG but obviously he passes out
and Tom Cruise has to basically help him
fix this helping place he gets hit by
lightning mid Skydive yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's right how unlucky
go to be fair they do the halo jump in a
thunderstorm so so you know you know
it's not like kind of asking for it it's
not like they just jump out of the plane
and then God's just like I'm going to
Smite this one person you made it sound
like it was like Clear Blue Skies and
just like one strike it's like
unfortunately yeah so yeah Tom Cruise's
character has to help him fix
um fix his parachute and fix everything
in mid-air yeah
um and then they [ __ ] are able to
just land safely I guess afterwards but
it's all done in one show it's one
unbroken shot right
and Tom Cruise was talking about it and
they only had one take a day right
because it was shot right as the sun was
Rising yeah so they had one take a day
to do like this three to four minute
shot right which was a highly Advanced
skydiving technique and sky and Skydive
uh skydiving sequence where
what happens is the first shot is like
the camera guy had to literally fly out
and Tom Cruise had to fly out and he had
to catch up to the camera guy to like I
believe a few inches because it needed
to be in Focus right like he needed he
needs to catch up the cameraman and stop
mid-air at the right length for the
camera to be in Focus right before going
off past the cameraman and that just
that's [ __ ] insane how insane do you
have to be to
choreography
I want to see the yellow takes I'm just
like well Chris is running into the
camera
my head first yeah it's it definitely
hearing him talking about it and now
watching back to the sequence it's
definitely given me way more of an
appreciation to some of the [ __ ] that he
does on screen in his action movies
because I haven't seen Top Gun but I
thought everything was also done with
the same kind of mindset where we're not
doing we're not using CG we're doing as
much of this in real life as we possibly
because this stuff is crazy that movie
yeah what was the action scenes like in
that movie oh like nuts like you do
because it's all like real Jets I'm
pretty sure yeah at least for most of it
and yeah it's just crazy scenes like
really cool uh like choreograph scenes
between two Jets as well like yeah I
don't know it's sick it's a great movie
go watch it you'll love it okay if you
if you have an appreciation for that
you'll you'll like talking I mean I
loved the original Top Gun so yeah yeah
it's not as homo erotic sadly
yeah well because this one's more of
like a he's like a mentor I was ready to
take my [ __ ] top tier boxes with me
as well and everything just to me the
first one is just about you know uh him
being struggling with his gay identity
which yeah have you seen that Quentin
Tarantino
this is good short like Tarantino is
just [ __ ] talking about how top kind
of secretly a movie about gay guys yeah
like someone discovering their home the
homosexual side yeah in Top Gun isn't it
the movie about boys playing volleyball
because it's
it's Quentin Tarantino clip you could
ever [ __ ] imagine and just what's
what's funnier is just you see this clip
you scroll down to the comments and it's
just it's sometimes YouTube comments
like they double the uh the
entertainment clip they're like so this
is a Wendy's
that's so good oh my God we're not like
another film I watched recently because
I don't know I don't actually watch many
films it's uh everything everywhere all
at once you guys watch that as well
recently pretty good [ __ ] incredible
amazing came at the same time as Dr
Strange and it's way better than it yeah
yeah exactly oh my God it's such a good
movie Choo choose which Multiverse
[ __ ] Multiverse of Badness and
Multiverse the the main goal is the same
actress in uh crashing tiger I think
yeah yeah Michelle yo Michelle yeah the
movie was amazing yeah I didn't know she
could speak English yeah yeah
well no no no no no because I'm crashing
tiger she doesn't right because she's a
really really famous actress in China
and I've only seen her speaking you know
Mandarin or Cantonese so I didn't know
if she could speak English or not and uh
yeah I didn't I didn't realize like how
much of that film is spoken in Chinese
I thought it was I I [ __ ] loved it
yeah it was really really cool yeah
because there are some films
like uh what's the other film uh what's
what's the film uh where it's a girl
meets a really really rich guy
um and it's like also based in like Asia
and [ __ ]
right
but they made a rich guy yeah I was like
uh they'll help me out here Nabi help me
out the one that was filmed in Malaysia
yeah yeah yeah so the one in Jackie Chan
is also filled with Malaysia oh [ __ ]
is every Asian romance just like [ __ ]
filmed in Malaysia but Romeo and Juliet
I have to have to have to look look oh
[ __ ] Michelle yo was in there as well
completely forgot oh my god of course
you can speak English I'm a [ __ ]
clown oh my God this is it's it's it's
it's on the [ __ ] tip of my tongue uh
why are you thinking about that though
like I think the one thing I really
appreciate about everything everywhere
was just like how I mean for one it's
[ __ ] hilarious yeah like but actually
like it's on the nose but it's not like
cheesy I guess it's really good and also
it's just really [ __ ] shot well yeah
like it's almost like it was almost like
an odd house if really watching that
gave me the same Vibes not not exactly
the same like tone but the same Vibes
it's like watching The Matrix for the
first time where they just had this
really really interesting idea yeah
right and they turned it into they they
took this concept which in The Matrix
was it's all virtual world and you can
break the rules of this virtual world
becoming Kung Fu Master and all that
yeah I had that I had that it had that
same kind of vibe where it's like really
Anything Could Happen yeah Anything
Could Happen yeah and it was a really
interesting concept and they explored it
in the most intro interesting way
possible yeah I felt like Everyone Cared
in that movie like every every every
little detail that yeah it felt like it
was really done to the utmost uh you
know like even some of the fight scenes
yeah the camera angles were oh my God
some of the car only feels crazy I mean
I mean we know that Michelle yogan
fights you know he's been in a lot in a
lot of action films
um so it was just yeah it was just a
[ __ ] because it was so weird because
it's like I feel any other movie would
like take the same Concepts that
everything everywhere had uh and would
just like really [ __ ] dumb it down to
the point where you wouldn't be able to
take it seriously like the bagel for
instance yeah yeah right like that like
that scene like was like I remember when
I was watching that I was just like oh
okay this is kind of dumb but then by
the end of it I was just like no The
Bagel like I was so invested in and I
was like don't go into the bagel and I'm
like
um and I just like stood back I'm just
like what am I saying why am I why am I
investing in this [ __ ] bagel yeah
it's it's one of the most refreshing
films I've seen yeah in a very very long
time I mean speaking of Matrix you're
saying I also watch Matrix resurrections
yes no it's Resurrection Revelations is
the uh [ __ ] needs a resurrection bro
yeah oh my God no it did not need a
residency
Top Gun if Top Gun is the perfect
example of a a lot you know a long
franchise coming back in a modern way
and it'd be and it'd be successful yeah
Matrix resurrections is the opposite
where they just tried to throw in as
much fan service as possible and they
try to be way too meta to the point
where it's just [ __ ] dumb I think
there's only like one person in the
world that enjoyed Matrix resurrection
and that's the one person who wrote that
script on fanfiction.com yeah because
that's what it [ __ ] felt like oh my
god did you watch it I watched it yeah I
haven't watched it just the whole meta
of the fact that's not so bad just the
whole matter of the fact that like Keanu
Reeves's character is the one that like
he's a game developer who created The
Matrix Games and then like Sony
Entertainment is just like we want you
to make the next Matrix game but it's
actually the movie that you're currently
watching somewhere I don't know well I
think I think we might as I think I
might have mentioned I feel like we've
had this conversation I can't remember
if it's been on camera or off but I
think that someone gets my yeah the one
thing though that I think pissed me off
the most yeah yeah I think the one thing
though that pissed me off the most more
than that was the fact that they
replaced uh Smith and Morpheus with two
different actors yeah yeah I'm just like
I I want Lawrence Fishburne I don't know
I don't know who this other guy is but
he's not he's not my Morpheus well
launch fish runs in John Wick yeah but
but
that's the new Matrix
I want the Hugo weaving mystery because
we've got this [ __ ] like when you
have Lawrence Fishburne and uh John Wick
when they meet in the thing you can feel
the energy yeah I can tell he's like he
like [ __ ] yeah how you doing
it's good I heard though that like they
didn't even like hit up Lawrence
Fishburne for this [ __ ] up new movie
and it's like how could you not like
he's such a pivotal yeah but like he's
such a pivotal actor in the The Matrix
fantastic and same with Hugo weaving as
well yeah yeah and then replace Mr Smith
instead of Hugo weaving like Chad mode
they replaced him with his [ __ ] like
he's a frat boy
man's a human fist bump yeah what the
[ __ ] did they do to him yeah he's like
he's like the Silicon Valley like crony
that you would never want to be friends
with I'm sweating for John Wick 4 now
because that's that got a they got a
it's trailer recently oh really oh yeah
it's got announced I'm pretty sure yeah
end of 2023 maybe well hopefully they
don't do a matrix I'm sure I'm sure it's
gonna be one two and three were amazing
I'm sure four will be amazing yeah I've
watched the first one yeah I've watched
the first one yeah all right and I do
want to watch the other two I just
haven't had the time I don't watch many
movies I I don't really know what's
going on but it's such a joy to watch
yeah I think it's everything because
there's such I never go back and watch
the previous movie so I remember one
quite well because plot was simple yeah
right and then two something happens
yeah and I'm not sure and then three I'm
just watching it and I'm thinking yes
but the choreography is just amazing I
mean you basically just describe the
Matrix yeah as well it's so good like
the fight scenes are so good in John
Wick it's just such a joy go going back
to uh going back to everything
everywhere once what I was trying to
remember the film I was trying to
remember was crazy Rich Asians oh yeah
yeah I I was generally going to say that
as a meme because I thought that's what
no that's that's that's literally I
didn't think that was the movie you were
talking about oh no no I was gonna Meme
and say that well because I was saying
what other what other film about uh
about Asia the word rich and Asian so I
was like yeah yeah that's why I was like
obviously
and he said Rich Asians
I was like what's the one with the rich
Asians and they're kind of crazy
that's why I was going to say it as a
meme because I was like there's no way
it would be that movie because he would
have remembered because there's only
really one [ __ ] movie about of rich
rich Asians
one of them like meets a rich person and
one of them's poor or whatever whatever
it was it was crazy Rich Asians but one
one thing that uh one thing that took me
out of that film yeah was the fact that
pretty much everyone spoke English to
that form right right and that's that's
what that's what took me out of that
film that's one thing I really really
liked about everything everywhere all at
once because I remember the the scene
that took me out the most out of crazy
Rich Asians was when the mum was talking
to the son and she was speaking in
English and I'm like there's no [ __ ]
way this would happen even if they're
bilingual yeah if if a mum is scolding a
son you know for a fact she's using her
mother tongue there is absolutely zero
[ __ ] way that she's going to be
speaking English and one thing I [ __ ]
loved is that they didn't give a [ __ ] in
uh in everywhere everything everywhere
all at once they there was such a mix
between subtitles where you know they
were speaking they're speaking Chinese
or Mandarin and there was you know
sometimes the daughter would just reply
in English yeah that's what I like even
in the opening scene when like the
husband and the the mama talking to each
other like half of it is mean like it's
it's like a yeah perfect mix of like
Chinese and then English and then right
back to Chinese you know like that's so
accurate the real life that's that's so
that's what it's like that's what it
would be like yeah yeah we don't speak
English like some people speak English
sometimes it's a [ __ ] mix sometimes
your mum says something to you in in her
mother tongue and you reply in English
because you can't be asked to [ __ ]
um even though like the setting for that
movie is so Fantastical the dialogue
felt so real it's it was so grounded in
like it was it it was so grounded in
reality as well in a sense where
characters actually acted uh like how I
recognized like I recognize how they do
in real life yeah and everything as well
yeah um and yeah it just it just made me
it just made me [ __ ] happy to see my
culture represented in this way you know
it's yeah just you know [ __ ] yes I
mean I feel like shows in general that
interweave languages into the story are
generally just like I mean you have to
you're already going out of the way so
much to do that right so like stuff like
narcos Breaking Bad all those kind of
shows that you get a lot of Spanish
actors and stuff yeah yeah it just it
just makes the world so much more
believable when you have characters that
are that would be bilingual or would
speak X language in that setting yeah
and it just shows that like oh somebody
cared a lot about details yeah you know
I don't give a [ __ ] I have to read some
subtitles for two seconds we're anime
watches yeah yeah exactly
uh maybe you watch that maybe you need
English subtitles I don't know yeah
sometimes maybe you're watching English
shows you're like I don't know yeah it's
like oh my God yeah because you know
obviously we're all bilingual here and
so it's it was just so refreshing just
to see like the bilingual life you know
be actually like represented in film
because I feel like for the longest time
Hollywood wood was just like so scared
of subtitles acceptable oh yeah like the
only place I ever saw it was like World
War II movies some reason World War II
movies okay German bad we subtitles you
know everywhere else it's just like okay
the bad guys are speaking English and I
don't know why but they're just everyone
just thinks especially just because like
as a as a director if you're only fluent
in English you might not have the
confidence to be like okay I trust that
these guys can do their thing yeah I
feel yeah now that you say that that was
like the one like tiny aspect of The
Last Samurai that I hated what's the
fact that like
some instance is where I'm like why are
you speaking English you are a [ __ ]
daimyo
interesting out English to Tom Cruise
I'm like that is not
it's not I'd like to think wherever Tom
Cruise goes people just start speaking
English yeah yeah it doesn't matter who
you are and then you're like trying to
like damage control it with like so Tom
Cruise is like yeah I can learn a couple
of lines of Japanese for this film and
just say it in a really [ __ ] accent it's
like no no no no no no no yeah because I
think like finally we're getting to the
point where more like Multicultural
bilingual people have got have gotten
their way into the movie industry yeah
you can enable are able to handle this
at a level that's you know satisfactory
to the audience yeah because before it
was like yeah you know [ __ ] Germans
in World War II movies or Russians I I
I'm kind of thinking if there's any
other languages that was like subtitled
a lot or like you know any any proper
languages that you see in a lot of
Hollywood films but it's because every
other European language would just be
like oh let's just get an American actor
kind of speaking English in that
country's accent yeah yeah so it's like
if it was like a French character you
would never hear them speaking French
they would just speak English in a
French accent yeah it's like yeah he's
French trust office if if it was like a
[ __ ] Middle Eastern it was in the
Middle East then you'd never stop
talking to those characters you know
that was just that was just a random
woman at a store yeah
yeah perfect English
with
me through some [ __ ] like that you know
that's true yeah sure so yeah watch
everything every all at once one of the
best movies I've seen in a long [ __ ]
time I agree yeah such a good one trying
to think if there's anything else I've
watched recently I still haven't watched
also you watched it you finished it I
haven't yeah I haven't yet
I never even watched breaking back
I like the I like the scene where Mike
Charles Walter to put his dick away
that's in Breaking Bad right nothing
Breaking Bad oh why do you love this one
I don't know you know when you discover
like a video and you end up watching it
like five times a day you know that's
that's that's the that's the points you
just walk past like God's house on the
walls here put your dick away Walter
like that
why are you laughing so much
I like the scene where the guy says you
can call me sauce
I'm I'm very glad that Breaking Bad
memes are still in like it's been it's
been how many years and Breaking Bad I
think it's just do not die I think it's
because of better it's because of better
wonders yeah but all the memes are from
breaking bad stuff I know like they're
all Jessie and you know there are some
soul memes but it's mainly all Jesse
it's kind of getting to the point where
Breaking Bad memes or can I get into the
point of like SpongeBob you know where
yeah it just it just lives on and memes
and I don't know why the memes have just
lived on like you think that they would
have exhausted all of the me material
because it shows like how many years old
but they still like the memes keep
refreshing and they keep getting like
good new memes and I don't know [ __ ]
how
um but yeah like Better Call Saul I've
heard amazing things about it so good
Sydney will not stop raving about it
it's so so good yeah you've got to watch
so it's like a spin-off uh prologue
prologue okay it says before but it's
about uh the lawyer following his life
you say loyal as if I know the
characters
I know the name song
honestly it's it's like the ancient meme
of like soul and it's like it's so good
man like it's held up like as good as
like it's as good as Breaking Bad yeah
I've heard that so so good I've played
the final Seasons like nutty it's insane
like it's so good and at the time
recording there's literally one more
episode out in like a few days yeah but
it's it's so [ __ ] good well Joe you
finally watched the boys right watched
as in the first two episodes okay the
first two episodes but I I highly
um why haven't you continued it
because I just haven't really had the
time to sit down and watch it yeah so
before season three was amazing yeah but
like uh so far first two episodes so far
has been [ __ ] amazing I just love
Carl Urban everything he does it's great
yeah he's like one of my favorites I
still I still gotta watch season three
oh she's
good is it the best season so far you
reckon I think for me yeah probably I
think out of all the seasons it's
probably the best one because I I think
I enjoyed season one the most I've only
seen the first two seasons uh season two
I heard season 2 is a bit of a Slowdown
right there was some really slow moments
in Season Two Season one was just like
every episode was a banger season two uh
had a good beginning had a good ending I
think the middle was a bit was a bitter
um still waiting to watch season three
because Sydney wants to watch all of the
boys together again and I'm like can I
can we just started he's already seen it
huh she's already seen it yeah she's
already seen the first two seasons but
she wants she wants to refresh her
memory because uh that's a lot of time
to put into refreshing your memory so
like a recap on YouTube or something or
just go to movie clips YouTube channel
and just like watch all the clips you do
not know that it is so excessive it's
it's like watching TV series you get
nerfed when you're in a relationship and
you start watching together you actually
get [ __ ] nerfed do you get this joke
Yeah because sometimes you just want to
watch your head by yourself but like I
think like she would get less offended
if I like slapped her mum then if I
started the boy season three by myself
I'm I'm the opposite right now because
Aki just caught up with all of the um
stranger things like seasons and I'm
just like can we start again from season
one it's just like [ __ ] you no why is it
yourself you little [ __ ] I'm like all
right [ __ ] yeah because you watched the
crown together with Aki as well yeah
yeah
that's great I love that series I'm
still waiting for the next one I don't
know sometimes I just I just I just like
watching things at my own pace yeah you
know and especially now there's time is
limited you know free time is limited
and when when I feel like watching the
boys or when I feel like watching this
TV series rewatching season one and two
that's a bit excessive you gotta shut
that down yeah that's kind of you gotta
you gotta stop that right now yeah no no
no she's not how we're doing TV once
we've watched something we've watched it
so we can't agree on it which is why I
haven't started Seasons which is the
sole reason why we haven't started
season three just tell her no we're
doing this
but I'm married now I'm married I'm yeah
that means you have more leeway to say
yeah yeah what are you gonna do divorce
me
she'd be like we're not doing this we're
not watching something like that am I
the unreasonable one here I think I
think she's fine so why don't you get
divorced she wants to watch she wanted
to watch the boys yeah that counts as
like diabolical
but you also watched uh Invincible right
yeah yeah
that was oh my God that was such a good
series like I knew I was gonna enjoy it
because of all the memes that I saw and
just from like the concept of it because
like you know we were talking about
Marvel before right and like I am so
much better I am definitely in that camp
of I'm so [ __ ] sick of the just
trophy superhero yeah and then finally
and then when I read about the concept
for invincible I was like oh [ __ ]
finally yeah you know this this seems
way up my alley and I watched it and I
remember I think it was either you or
you or both of you were saying like yeah
it's it's like a really violent Series
yeah and I was watching through episode
one and I was just like there's not
really nothing really violent about it
and then after the credits you know
is like oh oh oh oh oh that's when I was
like oh this is something special oh
yeah yeah I was like oh okay now we're
talking hell yeah and then yeah I binged
it in like two days while I was in LA
and it was [ __ ] amazing such a good
show I finally I finally got to see all
the memes in in in context I finally saw
the think Mark think Meme and I'm just
like oh that's where that's from okay
it's it's like it's such a good feeling
where you watch a series where you've
only consumed it through memes and then
you finally see that mean moment and
you're like it makes so much sense now I
get it that was me with the entirety of
SpongeBob because I didn't grow up with
SpongeBob because we didn't have
Nickelodeon when I was growing up right
and I only actually sat through and
watched all of SpongeBob like last year
or the year before how much of SpongeBob
is there there's a lot like five or six
seasons but like no no no no no no
there's like [ __ ] 30. is there yes uh
but only the first four seasons Madam
okay okay that changed foreign
statement on that because honestly after
like I started watching season five and
it just like I don't know what happened
it's like with kind of like with the
Simpsons where it's like I don't know if
they like changed riders or something
like that but like the uh the Creator
left oh the Creator left okay yeah oh
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] yeah I know I know you
told me he left and like Nickelodeon
took it over right well they took it
over anyway but I think he had no say in
it anymore yeah it's like a lot of the
the charm was kind of gone yeah
like it felt like SpongeBob and it was
SpongeBob but like the jokes just didn't
hit anymore yeah and I was like oh it
was just like a sudden change all of a
sudden as well and then Aki was like
yeah honestly anything past this point
is just kind of also like SpongeBob
became like the face of Nickelodeon so
they like couldn't go get as risque in
some I think so I I don't know they they
rely on SpongeBob a lot like I think
like Nickelodeon's programming is like
majority SpongeBob like if yeah like I
don't know something about this Cartoon
Network they only [ __ ] plays Teen
Titans Go when I was in America I wanted
to watch Cartoon Network yeah it's just
Teen Titans Go all the [ __ ] time and
I was like 9pm and I want to watch
something I'm like what is this this is
[ __ ] yeah give me the normal Team Titans
well that's why like the early SpongeBob
seasons were so good because it almost
had like a Ren and Stimpy vibe to it
where it's just like it's some of the
jokes I'm just like oh yeah children
should not be consumed it's very adult
what made you want to just watch
SpongeBob because I finally got to the
point where I'm like I'm consuming all
of these SpongeBob memes and because
they're [ __ ] everywhere like you know
like like Breaking Bad they're just like
Timeless memes and I'm just like I kind
of want to know what the [ __ ] is
happening like I want to see these memes
in context right I like how you like
Thomas memes it's like put your dick
away well too
much Timeless means and so like you know
I was just like I'm finally gonna sit
down and just like because again like I
didn't grow up with Nickelodeon at all
so I had the same thing with avatar The
Last Airbender as well yeah like I
didn't grow up with that [ __ ] so like
three watched it like three years ago I
finally watched it because at one point
like everything was on Netflix yeah so I
was just like oh [ __ ] it it's on Netflix
I'm just gonna binge the whole thing
yeah that was [ __ ] amazing well like
because I haven't even I haven't seen
SpongeBob yet so none of the memes make
any sense whatever yeah I've never
watched it I I mean I've watched one or
two episodes fully of SpongeBob yeah
again I didn't have [ __ ] Nickelodeon
as a kid because I didn't have Sky TV
um because I if if it wasn't on channel
the the first four channels then I
probably wouldn't have watched it
unfortunately because I didn't have
cable
um so I never got the chance to watch
SpongeBob and so I I only know about it
through memes yeah I've always assumed
they're not meant to make sense you know
it doesn't watch TV huh it was on Welsh
TV with the Welsh dub really yeah well
how what's SpongeBob SquarePants and
Welsh I don't know I can't remember I
remember it said really weird though and
I even as a kid I was like I think I
think this the English one is way better
than this
but like what I really appreciated about
SpongeBob is the fact that like a lot of
the jokes that didn't end up being memes
I think are even funnier than the ones
that did end up being memes because it's
like again it's like it's it's like the
first couple of seasons of SpongeBob was
so good because it's like some of the
funniest jokes are some of the subtlest
ones yeah where like kids wouldn't get
it but the adults be [ __ ] cracking up
about it because it's like it's a little
too clever for it to be just packed away
as a children's show right I feel
um yeah and it's great it's [ __ ]
hilarious I love SpongeBob yeah I can
see now finally after watching like the
the all the funny Seasons absolutely
that's pretty good yeah okay the
original episodes are really fun really
funny yeah I might how did you end up
watching it because I don't know how you
would watch it here in Japan uh it was
on one of the streaming platforms I
think but I think recently now they took
it off because I think Nickelodeon is
trying to do what Disney plus is doing
where yeah there's Nickelodeon Paramount
I think it's Paramount right
the [ __ ] thing is there's so many
streaming services now that it's just
impossible to keep up on where
everything is at well it's because like
since Disney plop uh Disney plus started
popping off it's like every other
programming now it's just like oh we can
do that as well it's not just that it's
people are realizing oh people don't use
Netflix anymore or not as many people
use Netflix anymore yeah and yeah Disney
plus apps has been like absolutely
killing it in terms of like sales and
numbers which makes me yeah it does it
does this is gonna earn everything it
does make me sick it does make me sad
you're gonna own literally everything
yeah we're gonna we're all going to be I
mean we we've kind of get ready for the
national currency of uh Japan
Disney coins yeah
when's the Disney cryptocurrency coming
out that's probably going to be a more
stable coin again for crypto they'll
have their own fiat currency well
they'll take over like Venezuela or
something and they'll be like we should
buy it let's buy Venezuela Mickey coin
yeah we're making uh yeah Mickey coin
and then that's it
I'm telling you she's gonna own
everything yeah well like it's scary
they own so much stuff yeah yeah yeah
but like we've gone back we've gone back
to the point now where we it's basically
cable TV again where you you pay for so
many streets yeah and you don't know
where every stream you want to watch the
show and like I want to watch egg show
and I'm like where do where do I watch
it yeah which channel which which
channel is on you know at least with
cable you kind of got everything now you
can't get everything yeah now I'm like
oh [ __ ] I kind of miss having the bundle
where you've got everything in one even
now it's like an individual cable for
each I just like I I do not I just don't
it's it's gone back now where I'm like I
just don't want to pay for all these
streaming services like I have Amazon
Prime just because I want Amazon Prime
no not because I want to watch [ __ ] I
don't I I I'd rather like pull my eyes
out than use the Amazon Prime video
service it's awful it's so bad yeah and
then Apple TV [ __ ] off absolutely no I'm
not one I don't even own anything Apple
yeah even if there's a show I want to
watch on Apple TV like Severance how how
do I watch it I will pay money to watch
it but I'm not buying an apple thing and
I'm not buying an Apple TV so like now I
can't watch it all right you want to
watch something else it's on Paramount I
don't even know if Paramount had
something yeah and then CNN had their
own thing a while back that colossally
failed today yeah they did it was awful
and then Hulu
who who
else in America that's it's fine but
like outside of America sucks and then
like what else is there there's a Disney
plus I don't care about Disney I don't
want to watch Disney stuff yeah you're
not missing but if you don't care about
like Star Wars or Marvel there's
literally like no then maybe I want to
watch one TV show one time yeah exactly
oh [ __ ] me exactly
the thing is I I agree we have actually
not just devops it's worse now because
at least with Cable packages you could
cancel all of them at once you could
count they came with a bundle so you
could cancel the bundle that you wanted
right yeah now you you don't even know
like how to cancel most these Services
right that's what I [ __ ] hate it's
easier to cancel cable services than it
is to cast your [ __ ] subscription for
one of these Services it's an absolutely
[ __ ] night there's subscription
services that will manage your
subscription Services that's how out of
control subscription service has gotten
are you actually serious yeah yeah
there's like apps where you put in all
your stuff and you can manage them and
it will tell you when it's news and
stuff yeah what if I want to unsubscribe
that's how bad like this has got like
people just like I actually I genuinely
believe it's way harder to like manage
your money now than ever before because
like people are just paying for [ __ ]
that they don't realize and just keep
forgetting until you get the money taken
out like [ __ ] yeah yo dog I bet you got
subscription Services well did you okay
did you hear the thing about the BMW
cars what no so stop okay you're oh my
God you have not heard of this there's a
BMW car right you could buy and when you
bought the car to to have the heating
seat Heating and the seats enabled you
need to pay a subscription service
like look it up you'll see they they
were selling a car where if you wanted
to have the seats be heated it's it's
already in the car like yeah just to
enable it you to pay monthly yeah how
much do you have to pay it was something
it was a what 18 a month 18 a month 18 a
month for heated seats
uh for a year or 300 for three years 300
for three years what
what
yeah I was like that one actually like I
I never had a visceral reaction when I
heard that I was like you have like no
no no no no point isn't too far like
would you like to open your window we
are living the dystopian nightmare yo
Black Mirror was [ __ ] right man well
it's because they've taken like the
Ryanair approach to cars yeah I think
their argument was that the car is
cheaper for it yeah we're selling it
cheaper but if you want you can pay what
would be the normal price but you can
turn it on but I'm like this is stupid
because surely after X amount of years
you'll have made a profit on the fact
that I was buying heated seats I just I
just I hate it so much I hate the idea
of paying a subscription for oh God it's
just so dirty like I wouldn't I wouldn't
mind like I wouldn't mind subscriptions
so much if it was just as easy to like
sign off like to just exit the
subscription as it was to enter the
subscription but unfortunately [ __ ]
designs you know you wanna you wanna you
wanna cancel the subscription okay let's
uh let's hide this webpage [ __ ] like
five clicks in the small in the small
print and then you have to [ __ ] even
like the the ones where you have this ux
designer should be slapped the ones
where you have to email the service in
order to cancel your subscription [ __ ]
you yeah [ __ ] you okay actually actually
[ __ ] you if like you know I can kind of
understand if there's a button hidden
away in the user settings somewhere okay
I can kind of understand but if you have
to go out your way to message the
service to cancel the [ __ ]
subscription that is that's [ __ ] up
okay yeah but then you just do the you
cancel your card huh
just just cancel your card well I know a
lot of people oh my God that's a brute
force method it's like it's like I could
turn off my TV with the remote or I
could just pull the [ __ ] thing out of
the wall
like you on on I don't know about your
app um one of my uh apps it allows me to
cancel subscriptions from my bank oh
really so I can like tell it to stop and
it'll just [ __ ] pull my card out okay
um but there's also I know there's
something I thought you meant just like
[ __ ] setting your card
I know there's a service that I I don't
use it I'm too lazy but there's a
service where you can uh put your your
card into this thing and every time you
want to start your subscription it'll
make a new card within the this app yeah
and is that also a subscription service
I think so as well
but at least then you can like if you
want to give an app your credit card you
can give it a card that you can just
turn off anytime so if you want to like
just hard be like nah [ __ ] you yeah um I
don't know though I've never tried it I
I don't know how good it is I'm just
talking out of I asked and I've had it
online so yeah I don't know
literally anything anything is like uh
like I bought um
I bought those uh tile trackers right
and it's amazing right great but but one
one caveat and I didn't know this when I
was buying it there's like you don't
actually get to do everything with this
tracker it'll only tell you where it is
now and it has a function where it's
like do you want to see where it was the
last 30 days so you click oh you last 30
days oh pay three dollars a month to see
where it was a few days are you serious
yeah dead serious let me show you and
then like uh it's just a bunch of other
random [ __ ] and where it like debates
you yeah into like um
so if I go oh like smart alerts yeah
look so if I go smart alerts boom it's
like get more Go premium 30 30 pounds a
year yeah and it's like I I already paid
a lot of money for these stupid things
so like why why are you charging me a
lot of money I don't know I don't get it
to me it's like do you hate me what did
I do that makes you hate me this much
yeah [ __ ] we we're living we are
literally like living the dystopian
nightmare we're gonna be like cyberpunk
2017 micro transactions for every
necessity when is when when are when is
like gotcha gonna be more popularized in
the gaming industry I think it's only a
matter of time unfortunately I mean it's
I would argue it's already pretty
[ __ ] popular yeah what do you mean
this is [ __ ] rampant
yeah but I remember when gacha games was
just like oh that those are like the
weeb games right yeah and then everyone
else was complaining about
microtransaction but because of gentian
impacts you know unfortunately I'm also
against in player so I've like
contributed to the evil unfortunately
yeah
it's just like normalized now
unfortunately yeah I think it's gotten
to the point where people or even in
like other mainstream games I think so I
think so people don't bat an eye now
about dropping 100 bucks on a randomized
[ __ ] boxes and it's fine you just
don't specifically call it gotcha are
you talking about gacha or loot boxes
both okay loot boxes are catch yeah
that's what I meant they just don't
specifically say gotcha right they they
leave that terminology for the weeb
games but like everything else just like
yeah it just says another [ __ ]
synonym to that word and just pretends
that it's not gotcha yeah right it's
like no it's [ __ ] you gotcha yeah I
think gotcha is hilarious when it's
taking money from rich people but when
people are like broken doing it I'm like
oh yeah yeah this is sad yeah speaking
of subscription Services look at all
these patrons
oh my God
I know I know guys I know okay if you
wanna cancel your subscription please
email me at this is going nowhere
gmail.com
I kind of realized halfway through
um halfway through the subscription
service rant and when I'm like [ __ ] we
gotta shout out our patreon right after
this
is that you can complain to yeah exactly
if you'd like to join the system then uh
head on over to our patreon patreon.com
to a year also also follow us on Twitter
send using the subreddit if you had a
face listen to us on Spotify it's a
completely optional Service uh we'll be
doing the show anyway regardless so you
know you get the content anyway you get
the content anyway you don't have to
email us don't worry don't worry
patreon's nice enough where it's on the
side oh my god did you do that I
completely for guys yeah
um in that case see you guys next week
bye
foreign
[Music]